ray and the kids all right beside a
company together and we produce about 20
films and this was this was one of them
something that we came on board about
two years ago very very hard to put
together very hard to make the money
and then affecting the film is finished
as extraordinary right
so funny about this movie it seems so
obvious such an obvious film for the
third moment
and when we were putting it we were
joined finances it was so difficult
because everyone thought it was so nice
and that it would never sort of break
out
well we picked wrong
Smith and Edgar
you know I think it's a really difficult
time to get distribution for films a lot
of the companies that were around gone
out of business and I think a lot of
filmmakers have become more savvy about
what it takes to release their films and
it's great to have that option because
you don't want to be stuck or dependent
on people who may not be as passionate
as you'd be about your involvement yeah
it's a really exciting time I think I
think producers you suggest raising
money for films and get them films out
the door and just say you know goodbye
once it hit the distribution company and
now or should have start learning to
think about long-term how we're going to
get it out in theatres and how we're
going to utilize social media and really
sort of start to do yourself an
interesting time and I think really good
producers when they're done even if they
have a distribution company should be
very very involved in the process if you
learn to love my
no I think sometimes well I think we
recently very made tenacious and they're
making films but also you need a really
talented director who's going to execute
these films well and that really made a
difference in this case
we were very lucky like that
I think also
together you know we won
he said no he started to think outside
the box about how to raise money and how
to buy movies together you didn't just
have to go to fox searchlight a show me
should get your movie made and I think
that
I
so fun to be here and have this reward
for you know making the Bell it's been a
great process
they should behave thank you